ok ma che cazzo bella a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono qua
dj ed oggi siamo in un'ora prima di
cominciare agazzi come al solito dire
iniziare con la fondante della settimana
che questa settimana è stata vinta da
richard htt che ha fatto scoppiato
lavoro d'arte moderni c'è allora ragazzi
io non sono affatto metterci tutti i
personaggi in una fan art so se sei un
[ __ ] genio recha lascio linking
schizzare comunque ragazzi per chi
volesse vedere il video di come ha fatto
la fan altre perchè l'ha fatto sei un
genio
caso chiuso e detto queste ragazzine che
possiamo passare alle news perché allora
come prima news
credo che abbiate visto tutti e mi è
arrivato loculo swift è stata una cosa
abbastanza inaspettata perché non sapevo
che mi sarebbe arrivato in questi giorni
quindi la cosa io volevo di ragazzi che
con i prossimi nei prossimi vidoni sarà
fare anche gli horror con loculo swift
perché quei giochi che ho fatto era non
soltanto per provarlo diciamo che era
chissà che cosa
quindi ragazzi preparatevi perché la
seconda cosa io volevo di ragazzi e che
è praticamente mi è venuto il mal di
gola quando ho avuto la febbre quando
sono stato in vacanza e dopo mi è venuto
al mal di gola e anche adesso mi sto
sforzando per non farlo sentire quindi
ragazzi se mi vedete leggermente diverso
dal solito in questi giorni perché ho la
voce un po così quindi non vi spaventate
normale non sta mutando e poi giungono
dai ragazzi volevo dirvi che sta per
uscire in questi giorni il terzo
speciale secondo è stato un quello con
street e tutti i video che usciranno nel
loculo slip perché come loro chiedevate
in tantissimi ho voluto prenderlo per me
no riusciamo a fare tutti i giochi
possibili comunque la cosa volevo dire
che il terzo speciale è diversissimo
diversissimo da ogni video ed è anche
cortissimo però è una cosa che per farla
ci si sta mettendo tantissimo 4 ore ho
detto issimo e spero comunque che vi
piace ragazzi ha detto queste ragazzine
che le news possono finire qui anche
perché so che vi tartassano leggermente
le palle news però di non farlo è più
forte di me scusate direi che possiamo
passare allo scarto dei pacchi anche
perché succede altro no ragazzi non con
un miliardo di puck cioè sembra che si
rigenerano ogni volta che li che li
scarto se ne generano altri diversi
ragazzi questa questa volete vederla c'è
un cazzo è cascato un pacco aspetta c'è
voi ditemi che faccio agli anno fa
attaccata mario
io non saprei cosa dire però è vera è
veramente sexy questo sicuro di
ripartire da questi ragazzi perché essa
faccia mi inquieta troppo quindi la
ritaglio faccio così lo aprono aprono
alla faccia eccolo qui perfetto ragazzi
adesso adesso è molto più figo questi
ragazzi mela me la prendo al volo perché
da collezione praticamente di un che
l'ha mandato è un genio c'è un pacchetto
di figurine da scartare si chiamano fa
vi fa vi ho il ritorno dello youtube lo
apro adesso ciò paura di cosa posso
trovarci dentro mag
ecco cos'è ragazzi ho trovato due carte
una rarissima tra l'altro alla carta
magia fa vj tv bellissima evoca
specialmente l'altro vecchio mostro
rituale fa vj cosa è la seconda ragazza
e la carta più rara che abbia mai visto
della carta rituale fa pizzerie
bellissima questa gatta può essere
evocata soltanto tramite a vocazione
speciale con la carta fa vj tv che cielo
tra l'altro vi ringrazio di cuore per le
carte perché sono stufa st dei geni
comunque mi stupisco sempre di più i
ragazzi passerà il prossimo pacco perché
ce ne sono ancora 3 er nasca ragazzi una
scatola di scarpe mi state prendendo per
il culo fracchia è perfetto la prima
cosa ovviamente troll face perché senza
di questo non potevamo andare avanti
sembra giusto però allora vediamo che
cazzo ci posso trovare qua te cos'è ma
serio mi avete inviato una canon
ma è vero è finta secondo me vi state
prendendo per il culo perché c'è l'altro
al face perché sono né posti né infatti
cosa cazzo c'è qua dentro e io che per
un attimo ciò anche credo voto ma anche
a morire se sto coso non lo so però già
lo amo un pettine grazie di cui avevo
dire che non mi non mi pettino i capelli
brutti mi sta insultando che poi tra
ecco infatti mi servirebbe adesso che mi
si è ribellato sto ciuffo a caso
perfetto ecco adesso adesso è molto
meglio la vera che allora è diffi è
difficile di rafah vj continua i wanna
be the guy allora sentite
io non l'ho di gioco con la merlo ok ok
io lo scordate proprio che io continui
quella merda deve morire atrocemente chi
me l'ha consigliato stati miei capelli
stanno prendendo il sopravvento
una fantasia da vendere ragazzi non mi
spiego cos'è cos'è sta roba da casa
adesso ho capito perché c'era tretti
ragazzi un nuovo supereroe
l'uomo cornuto una cravatta enorme costo
scritto crismi ma per certi in un pacco
solo ho trovato tutta sta roba ma come
cazzo è possibile c'è anche un kit di
tronco molto gentile grazie mille però
con con questi capelli non c'è bisogno
del trucco per rimorchiare
[Musica]
il giorno che non vedo un cazzo come
prossimo [ __ ]
lei fa sarà l'ultimo ragazzi cos'è stato
dio a una busta della spesa grazie così
vado al conad una maglietta con su
scritto la nutella far restringere i
jeans non a tutti amico mio delle cuffie
aderito grazie bellissimo un cappello
mei di una nave questo è veramente
figure allora italia italia tutto italia
caso anche i tic tac dell'italia ma che
cazzo ma c'è qualcosa che non è
dell'italia stop accola 9 fece peppa pig
questo non è giuliana credo se italiana
novero perché c'è sfigata pauroso detto
queste ragazzine che possiamo passare a
farvi rispondere o fare abbastanza in
fretta ragazzi perché la mia voce sta
implorando pietà quindi concludo il
prima possibile fa vidi la prima cosa ti
viene in mente ora maiale effemminato
con un orso stitico poi rispondere
poi risponde fargli perché non continui
la serie su cleverbot ragazzi questo
però dovevo spiegare perché alla prima
mente hanno tolto il registratore vocale
in mente quando io facevo cleverbot per
dire le frasi e le dicevo a bocce poi le
trasforma ma il computer le trame
inscritte però sta cosa prima in the
clever bot l'ha tolta
non so perché aspettando che la rimetta
perché quella era la parte divertente di
cleverbot fini se se la tolgono diventa
un po più brutto quindi aspetto che
rimettono sta cosa
riprendo a fare clever 4 che mi
divertivo un casino quindi aspetto
soltanto quello risponde affari perché
non fai un video dove dici 19 curiosità
che non sappiamo su di te una per anno
mi sembra la cosa [ __ ] se volete ragazzi
faccio un video su sta cosa che mi
verrebbe un po lungo quindi faccio un
video direttamente
non lo so ditemelo voi ragazzi faccio st
domanda se anzi colgo l'occasione anche
pari km sperimenti chi sempre nella fare
domanda per i 20 ragazzi siccome il blog
di una voce quelli che faceva una volta
non avevano la fari domanda e mi sono
abituato a farli senza il più delle
volte anzi mi dimentico di farla quindi
è normale sono stupido e per questo da
perché ogni volta me la dimentico poi mi
arrivano commenti del tipo fa vicky
linciano vivo perché dimenticato affari
domanda avrebbe essere reato
perseguibile da adesso in avanti sono
file affari domandata arrestano prova
bene usate non sono armato non ucciso
nessuno avere grassi come fuori domanda
mi dedichi vi chiedo la cosa di prima
viva se faccio un virus 19 curiosità su
di me che non sapete chi ragazzi detto
questo dire che posso concludere qui se
il video è piaciuto passato è stato il
commento mi piace anche a pagliari
facebook.com nonino tra tale iscrizione
a severi si discute né civili diavolo
prossimo video della ragazzi